[Music]
today's question comes from dan in
washington dc
i'm a landlord who owns multiple rental
properties over the past year or two
rent prices have seen a big increase
this is great for a landlord but not so
great for the tenant i know i need to
raise my rental rates to keep up with
the increased overhead costs however
this causes direct hardship to my
tenants that have been good tenants for
the past few years as a christian this
is hard for me i would feel bad if
raising rent caused them to have to move
after they've made the house their home
i did not get into real estate to
subsidize people's living expenses but i
also didn't get into real estate to
displace families either i love
investing in real estate so i don't see
myself exiting this field so i'd like to
hear your advice on how to balance this
equation
[Music]
it is
sweet
that um
you've got a big heart like this
and that's a nice thing
and you're not exiting the landlord
field
and so you are going to have to learn to
balance your faith
with business practices
that are not dishonoring to your faith
treat other people
like you would want to be treated
okay
i lease a
building
uh for
ramsey solutions
that is an office warehouse we're not
the owner of it uh about five miles from
where we sit right now from our
buildings that we own and uh the
lease is coming up for renewal
if the guy raises my rent to market
rate
why does that make him a bad christian
that was a passive aggressive question
the answer is it doesn't
okay i own
rental property single-family homes
among many other properties that we own
and if i raise my rent to
be market rate
that does not make me a bad christian
i did not displace the person out of
that house if they can no longer afford
it the marketplace did
the economy did
the ratio of the income that they earned
to their housing expense displaced them
i didn't cause
any of that and so you are not
displacing them you're taking too much
credit for
what's going on
uh if they need to move to a cheaper
house because they can't afford they're
going to move to a lesser house
because if they move they're going to
pay market
rent
now having said all of that
i've had situations because i manage the
properties with a heart and a head both
i don't personally manage them but we do
my family does
that someone is sick
um
i'll just you know i remember one time a
long time ago a lady had cancer
am i going to evict someone in the
middle of chemo
no
not i'm going to work with them i'm
going to be kind i'm going to have clear
conversations i want to know what's
really going on
i don't want to be
duped by the situation but on the other
hand i also want to be treat other
people like i'd want to be treated
that's a biblical mandate
and so if i were in that situation how
would i want to be treated well i'd love
some mercy some grace
but mercy and grace because rents went
up in general
and i can't afford to live here anymore
because my job didn't go up as much as
the mark as much as the cost of a loaf
of bread or gallon of gasoline went up
because welcome to inflation
um this is not something you caused now
you can cause the cancer either but that
is a temporary thing this other thing is
going to be there forever
that family is never going to be able to
afford to live there if they can't
afford to live there
it's not going to change now if they
come in and go i'm getting a raise in
four months and here's the contract can
you wait then yeah i'll give them a
little mercy you see what i'm saying
yeah but this idea that you have to
equate christian
and kindness
uh
not having good marketplace experience
is not true that's a that's a that's a
it's not a factual way of viewing this
and you brought this up with a caller
earlier who was kind of experiencing a
similar situation and you said hey this
is being a good steward of the the asset
that you are managing and uh you know he
says in the question that they've made
their hou the house their home it's not
their home it's your home it'll never be
their home as long as they're renting it
good point and when you're a renter you
kind of know that yeah i've been a
renter and i i didn't expect to stay
there
i'm passing through you know no one that
rents very few people that rent go i
want to be here 50 years i think i'm
just going to stay in your house for 50
years
you know no one does that this is my
forever home i'm a renter no one says
this
and honestly people don't say you know i
like taking it situation by situation
and going is this a true hardship or is
it really you've got to tighten up the
budget and so at that point i may give
them some resources maybe some ramsey
resources say hey here's the total money
makeover i want to help you create that
margin i'd love to keep you as a tenant
you've been great
and how you interact with them in
kindness is fine too you don't have to
be unkind you don't have to be cold and
transactional you can go understand it
hurts my heart
but i'm doing this with all these things
now if you've got a property that's gone
way up maybe you stage it up
and that's how you'd want to be treated
if you were there treat other people
like you won't be treated but if you
really would expect to get to live there
on rental rates that are 75 percent of
the market forever just because your
landlord's a christian then you've got
something screwed in your brain
you really do that's just not how it's
not that is not a calling of the bible
that is not something scripture calls us
to
to under charge because we're christians
now we don't need to overcharge we don't
need to rip people off we certainly want
to tell the truth
and those kinds of things we're not
trying to take advantage in some way
but sometimes people get in their head
that anybody that sells anything can't
be a christian
you know i can't believe you don't just
give all your stuff away ramsay
all these people that work here 1100 of
them that want payroll they require that
i don't give my stuff away because they
like for their payroll checks to clear
that's how this stuff works that's why
we sell a book instead of giving away a
book
um can i personally afford to give you a
two dollar ten dollar twenty dollar book
yeah i can personally afford to do that
but i gotta make sure that the people
here eat that work on this stuff and so
it's not an unchristian act to have
interaction in the marketplace it's a
good word